Tell us about some of
the worst examples of hate speech
here in Slovenia. Yeah.
Well, how explicit can I be
These are all by former government
or their supporters,
not anonymous trolls.
We had an authoritarian government
Most of the hate
tweets ex-prime minister brought into
the country was online
hate speech
concentrated on sexism, racism,
racism against immigrants, Jews, Muslims,
black people, women,
especially independent women.
Logica. Yeah.
And and so, again,
we decided to speak up,
and in that moment, we became victim.
One guy was standing outside,
and when he recognized me,
he had
a feeling that he can do anything to me.
You invent the enemy,
you describe the enemy,
and then you develop
a collective psychosis.
This new totally abnormal normality
is the real danger
My name is Nico,
and I am a director of an organization
called the Institute of Smart.
We are a movement We are giving the voice
to the people who are usually not hurt
and so on.
Their Facebook.
We don't want positions
in the government.
We don't want fancy jobs.
We are a group of young women
and what we want is change
in the society.
Now,
radical.
So these are the tweets
from ex-prime minister about me.
Just some of the tweets
and tweets.
Were they a tweet?
Which is
basically like saying like, let's burn
the activists of Nico Kovacs
and then names of some other activists.
This one is from one journalist
saying that I am mentally ill
This one is basically saying that someone
is preparing a gun to shot
all our activists.
There is more
and more tweets
which are saying that I am a bad woman
because I don't have kids.
It
would be so.
But still, my equipment yeah.
And
the fact
that he
stated
that it is the most powerful.
Yeah.
Still threatened to veto my first
I paid like around 200 for it,
even if I paid like first money.
But secondly, like,
they're using it to show that, like,
I don't work and that I'm lazy
and, like, part of the elite
You feel hopeless, you feel powerless.
You can change the laws,
you can change the structure,
but you also need an immediate response
to that kind of behavior.
When I do an eco concrete
no say one for scooping up with
is to see more of you see the beetle.
Obviously no active shooter, U.S.
military secretary
to a committee in the basement.
Would you be able to save
Becky blown apart in a seizure.
Did you see Christmas Day total
It was to this white elephant
in the sterile cocoa to the glue that
cracks is to be stated by
the state lovely woman.
I don't mean much more than a sweat
in the town of Positano in
we want to leave us with stumbles.
Let's keep her there.
Theme acid
keeper keep oil said female rescued the
politically cougar the father
but they move this pool
a school naked
It could be spread in the morning Canada
mother
could
lose her companions
some of the women
who will endure similar style
in the New Rochelle
new them the little attacker
who they believe are in business class.
In fact
up
who to be or through allows you
to be here.
Let's keep this case a group
that is mother to quote for the
most embarrassing rhetoric.
Not all you get an opportunity.
We keep the
I really want to invite people to join
like the campaign.
I don't have a feeling that
it's becoming a movement that people
basically are really excited about it.
So I think we have quite
a lot of work to do.
I am a little
bit nervous because today
this meeting is the first time
that we will try
to sit
across the table with someone
who is like a minister
and try to just explain to them
what we believe and what is wrong.
And
and look, they're glad we did it.
This massive
Israel is located on the beach.
A grizzly bear is a
tiny Quebec
parliament documentary gibberish.
Zuma McGoldrick, Reuters.
Tapper
Do you have some
you show your cool to the
bottom of the beach in a war?
Gosh,
I'm excited about the global recession.
The death knell of the Beatles
hit on my career with Mike with me.
Come on,
the Muppets nightclub
to sustain free automaticamente
out of the blue eyed
pogo was supposed to soften and serenity
from medial to tumble,
I believe, as each to Pagliacci
will be to give
the there's a lot of potential
to be honest with a smile
with the Benoit
possible good and Pataki knows the iconic
bold article
personification is a
symbol I promise I'll do so.
But he's ready to name a player in the
throes of regular TV so that there
will be duplicate standards and zero
threat
It's disappointing
when you feel like you've
managed to get access to the place
where change is supposed to be made,
but the reality isn't as simple
Where do you go from there?
There is no simple solution.
It's a thing that needs to be discussed
both at the level
of leaning media
of multinational corporations
and platforms
such as Twitter and Facebook.
As well as
discussions within the society.
Why free speech as such is unacceptable,
why it's extremely dangerous
I was attacked on
one of the main streets in Havana.
The guy just pushed me really hard
since he was screaming,
I will kill your thug,
like you just need to be quiet. And
I thought, like,
that moment
that I will just forget about it.
But every single hate
comment is making that attack more strong
and more serious.
You know,
you look at me
okay, sir.
Yeah.
This is the dress.
The former prime minister tweeted,
Let's have a beer summit.
This
to it.
We posted this 4 minutes ago,
and in 4 minutes
we already got 31 likes and free service.
So he did a good commercial
for our campaign.
So a lot of good stuff,
super nice things about that.
I don't think that it went wrong
in Slovenia.
I think it's a global issue.
But what we can do,
we can still do it in our community.
And this is what we are doing
Hate speech has come to the point
in which it's considered official,
it's considered
permissive, it's considered normal.
So let's try to go back
and to teach people
how to express themselves
and what is good and what this bad
we need to have,
like an organized army of kindness
or organized army of people
who are really determined
to bring back solidarity
and hope into the public discourse.